[Música]
imaginem que o governo previa uma carta
onde vou explicar vá que passariam a
receber um rendimento garantido
este empreendimento estarão disponíveis
para trabalhar para estudar através do
para fazer fosse o que fosse em nome
dessa gerado essa carta não se
perguntava serão ricos serão povos serão
ativos ou inativos pagava de 100
perguntas desempregados empregados
querem cientistas milionários indigentes
todos receberiam um rendimento igual
a intenção deste rendimento garantido
teria ainda esta carta que vocês
receberam seria financiar as vossas
escolhas sejam elas quais forem estudar
tocar música no metro fazer acrobacias
numa rua cheia de turistas
shah um negócio ou mesmo passar todo o
dia na praia fazer certo um rendimento
garantido para todos
diria essa carta não tem preferências
além de uma referência óbvia que
escolheu a vocês conseguem imaginar
investimentos sejam lembrados com uma
série de idéias parecidas sobre os quais
ouviram falar nos últimos tempos
o governo irlandês está a fazer uma
experiência com um rendimento garantido
que paga aos desempregados
o pnuma amor o candidato da esquerda às
eleições presidenciais francesas colocou
no seu programa de governo rendimento
universal paga o smartphone sítio e
financiado com uma taxa aplicada às
grandes fortunas
o fundador da tesla mas que diz outro
dia que provavelmente só o rendimento
garantido conseguir resolver o problema
do desemprego que será criar pela
automação mas o rendimento garantido
para todos é muito mais do que isto é
universal é para toda a gente
é paga ricos e para pobres e esta
contradição esta aparente contradição
usar força policial estava vocês todos
olhassem presta idéia como um código
aberto que precisa de linhas e precisa
todos vocês sem cintos remarem com esta
idéia
adicionem linhas de código e tenta
envolver as muitas fragilidades que essa
idéia ainda está aí vai a poderosa
promete pelo menos pra mim pensar que as
nossas vidas podem mudar de forma
radical mas o código que só evoluirá as
pessoas como vocês se interessarem por
ela no código já há alguns anos de
profissão foi tal nessa altura que eu
larguei o que estava a fazer e fui para
oxford como bolsa de carne inteiramente
a este assunto durante um primeiro tempo
com lorde inglês do partido trabalhista
ficava atenta a tensão extrema com
enorme entusiasmo como ficava a outra
paixão deu que a observação de pássaros
e garantimos que na altura já se falava
do rendimento garantido apenas resolver
os problemas das minorias e dos mais
desfavorecidos
muito antes disso thomaz nonô no seu
livro utopia terá sido o primeiro a
falar no rendimento básico a ser pago
aos mais pobres
mas eu queria dizer vos que ninguém
escreveu sobre esta ideia de forma tão
intensa de forma tão sólida com 11
filósofos belga com capel a pop star
chamado felipão paris quando eu publicar
nos anos mais tarde um livro chamado
será que as chances devem ser
subsidiados grande intenção que eu tinha
nesse livro era permitir que mais
pessoas como vocês centers a sua obra no
país se interessassem pela idéia com o
argumento com que eu defendo o seu
rendimento garantido este felipe para o
país
é um homem que fez toda a sua vida
próxima da esquerda
quando eu escrever o seu livro em 95 um
livro chamado bill feira informou a data
real para todos
o filme custou ideológicas mas talvez
não essas mais óbvias em que podem estar
a pensar em sua primeira intenção era
tentar mostrar que esquerda e direita
essa liberdade real para todos são
compatíveis
sua última intenção era tentar
demonstrar com a liberdade real para
todos nós tirar capitalista pode ter uma
boa justificação e tenho certeza que
neste vai e vem
todos se recordam a idéia original se
quiserem a diferença original que
existem esquerda e direita
aquela diferença fundacional que nos
ajuda a perceber que a esquerda defende
a igualdade ao ponto de permitir difícil
não lembrar pra curtir essa ideia de uma
distribuição igual para todos e que é
direta fundacional esse princípio mais
libertário o oposto isto é não se
importa de sacrificar a igualar se isso
permitir proteger a liberdade de todos o
que foi limpando paredes tenta e vai
dizer-nos nesse cove continua aberto à
espera das vossas linhas na edição e
retorno no livro da real para todos
conseguiram fazer aqui vai entendendo
suas vidas e terão os meios disponíveis
para concretizar essas intenções para
com tudo isto é simples não deu teórico
são sempre os mais simples
imaginem uma chance na dúvida apenas por
países e por lá e essa sociedade treze
países
começava com uma distribuição feita
mente igual terra por ano o que
acontecer rapidamente nesta tirada que o
craque faria o que cultivava rapidamente
todo o seu historial de terra e hoje
mais dava ao user ocuparia acho que
gerem cultivaria apenas uma parte da sua
terra e ficava confortavelmente
o resto tempo nesta sociedade é que o
felipe vai parar nos vêm dizer é que
explorava ao contrário do que estamos
habituados a pensar não é o mais pobre é
que está a ser impedido de exercer a sua
liberdade real para todos é o mais rico
frase porque ocorre rapidamente se
perceberia que aquela terra que o haiti
não cultiva eu podia cultivá lá eu
poderia torná-la ventava então o filho
para explica 80 explicamos que essa
liberdade real para todos é um jogo dá
oportunidade a oportunidade de ver a
terra
cleise de valorizá vai justificar a
existência de um valor alto rendimento
garantido para todos sem que nenhum deus
considera estar a ser alvo de uma
injustiça
eu sei que na vida real tudo isso
complica
tenho a certeza que muitos de nós estão
a pensar bom mas isso não significa que
eles viviam à custa dos outros
isso não significa que a província a mãe
teria eles teriam mais leves
isso não significa até que seriam de
província está a dar dinheiro também aos
mais ricos
eu acho que é um país rico em recursos
naturais e todos os anos quer ver tanto
acho que cada cidadão do alasca com
rendimento anual
vai que é pago juntamente com essas
receitas provenientes desse fundo que
gere os recursos naturais
ninguém no alasca considera injusto que
os ricos e os pobres recebam o mesmo
valor em macau acontece exatamente o
mesmo a uma fatia do jogo que é
distribuída por todos os que ocupam
nacional está a dizer é que eu não quero
um rendimento garantido para todos que
precisa da existência de povos de
assistência dos empregados da existência
dos fatos it para que nós
eu quero um argumento suficientemente
sólido para que nós pensemos que
possível forjar um novo contrato social
aquilo que vai parar a gente quer
é que eu não quero entusiasmar olhar é
que não devemos discriminar qualquer
forma de vida pagar um rendimento
garantido um surfista é tão legítimo
como pagá-lo a cristiano ronaldo é a
beleza do jogo das oportunidades que
torna tudo isso possível é que o que eu
quero fazer com a minha vida abre a
oportunidade por que vocês façam outra
coisa qualquer
com as nossas filhas são as
oportunidades que o deixou livre para
que outros aproveitam tac ou exemplo vai
também justificam a existência no
rendimento garantido
eu consegui as nossas caras que agora
estão a pensar como é que se financia
max paga um rendimento garantido a todos
há alguns anos eu escrevi uma coluna que
então publicada no jornal um país onde
tentava fazer as contas desta maneira em
portugal gastou cerca de 18 milhões de
euros com pensões subsídios de
desemprego e rendimento social de
inserção
se excluirmos as contas às pensões
somaram cerca de cinco mil milhões de
euros ativa são cerca de cinco mil os
portugueses que permitiria pagar mil
euros por ano a cada português
eu sei que é pouco e por isso em 2015
uma outra coluna escrevi um outro texto
quando tentava fazer as contas de outra
maneira
suponho que o banco central europeu
entre 65 mil euros anuais é caro pelo
ativo 275 milhões pelos ativos tanto
custam dia seria um ponto 3 trilhões de
euros parece menos as políticas de
expansão monetária seguidas pelo banco
central europeu eletromar hidravião
financiam um ex mesmos objetivos através
do sistema financeiro com 3.33 milhões
de euros três vezes mais e sem a
garantia de que o dinheiro chegará às
mãos das pessoas e se assiste em
portugal significaria que todos os anos
recebemos 25 mil milhões de euros e que
permitiriam entregar a queda português
cinco mil euros anuais todos os anos
economistas como martin wolf do
financial times o jornal valor
estão a defender neste momento
ativamente esta ideia não é a ausência
de dinheiro que impede essa função são
os nossos por um site um rendimento
garantido para todos é um instrumento
para viabilizar formas de vida formas de
vida diferentes exatamente o fato de
pensar de forma diferente o que abre
espaço para financiar este modelo como
vai parar e acredita que o modelo do
crase evil live ajudar a explicar o que
eu estava querendo vocês
acreditas ficarem este assunto fizerem
energia na tentativa da junção de todas
as dificuldades de cobre que ainda tem
um dia e é provável que acertemos este
jogo tão facilmente como aceitamos jogar
uma no pólo em que independentemente da
posição que cada jogador no tabuleiro
que estão o poder e estão a ganhar
quando pensamos na casa prática todos
temos o mesmo
[Aplausos]
[Música]